I think one of the more interesting
stories here is that Joe Biden will not
be on the ballot in New Hampshire which
is strange and there are activists
staging a right in campaign for Joe
Biden which surprised me I was watching
Fox news earlier and they interviewed a
woman who was holding up a sign saying
write in Joe Biden I was like I've never
seen a Joe Biden supporter before I
guess there are some when they have to
write in they appear yeah I mean I guess
that happens but you know while many
people are talking about what's going on
with the Republican primaries how it's
basically a big waste of time Trump's
going to win and they're trying to keep
Trump's name off the ballots in the
states Democrats have just basically
shut down their primary not allowing
anyone to challenge Joe Biden so why is
he not on the ballot and and what's the
strategy here uh they changed their
rules uh so they stripped Iowa the first
in the nation caucuses of their
delegates to try to discourage them from
having caucuses they didn't have them
the New Hampshire primary is mandated by
New Hampshire state law not the
Democratic National Committee rules so
to punish them for having uh the primary
anyway uh they both strip them of their
delegates within the convention and
Biden doesn't put his name on the ballot
now New Hampshire is a state where
writing in a name is really very simple
D Eisenhower won the Republican primary
there for he wasn't even on the ballot
he won as a WR in in 1952 Henry Kat
Lodge won the nomination or the primary
there 1964 and right it's very simple to
do uh now they they fear being
embarrassed by this little known
congressman who did file for the primary
Dean Phillips who I don't know much
about so now they are hustling to get
out a vote for Joe Biden well there's
Maran Williamson as well and Marian
Williamson I don't believe Jen yuger is
on the ballot in New Hampshire either uh
I I'm not following that I know that
he's gotten on in some states but of
course he was not born in the United
States or two American parents so uh
there's a Supreme Court ruling basically
I mean there's a constitution saying you
have to be a a natural born citizen but
there was also a ruling uh already
rejecting his argument as to why after
being you know Jen yuger is arguing that
he is a a citizen in full rights as same
as anybody else so he should be allowed
to run there there's an interesting
argument to be made there but I don't
know if he's going going to appear on
the ballot but I would say that if even
with this rting campaign I think it's
possible that Marian Williamson wins
this one maybe I mean the the big
tension for me is that now the DNC has
really isolated the New Hampshire uh
branch of the democratic party they'
they sent them there the um assistant um
the Assistant Attorney General sent this
letter to them I think it was like two
weeks ago it was a season assist letter
saying you cannot in writing which they
did the the rules committee for the DNC
sent a letter to the New Hampshire
Democratic party saying uh if you hold
anything during the primary it's
meaningless and you should not encourage
voters to do anything and this is
discouraging people from voting this is
a voter interference voter suppression
and it's really building tension between
this party and this National Mega group
that says you guys have to comply with
what we want even if it's against your
state laws I would say it's
anti-democracy wouldn't you I would too
I mean it's actual voter suppression to
say it's it's meaningless right that's
crazy well look the Democratic National
uh selection process was pre-wired their
first real contest is South Carolina
where you have an absolute majority of
African-American primary voters uh
I I have predicted for some time Joe has
had the the the way cleared for him to
win enough delegates to be nominated but
that would not stop him just before the
Democratic Nation convention which just
happens to be in Chicago to announce
that he's decided not to run for reasons
of Health throw the convention open uh
to uh uh to the selection of another
candidate Michelle Obama will say oh I'm
not interested I don't want it I don't
want it no thank you I don't want to do
it okay I'll do it
what'll happen is she'll say oh no no no
I I couldn't do it and then you'll start
hearing chants of Michelle Michelle be
drafted and she'll smile and then Brock
will come out and he'll say I think this
nation needs a leader and I'm going to
ask you right now here on stage to take
this responsibility for this country and
answer the call and she's going to wipe
away a tear and say I'll do it and
they're going to go maybe Fain becoming
like the biggest beta male on Earth
he'll be like I am the first man what
say I am the first man I look I've been
predicting this openly for two years I
see Bill oy had a column today I still
think she will be the nominee of the
Democratic Party by the way I think
she'll be a very strong formidable
candidate people who make jokes about it
are making a gigantic mistake I like a
year ago that's why I pegged too I mean
she's got the biggest star name she's
got the Obama name Superstar Hera
nonpolitical not viewed as political one
of the most admired women in the country
uh I I still think she will be their
strongest possible candidate so we we we
had we've had a bunch of uh potential PR
uh we we've had a bunch of predictions
as to what we think may happen one
prediction is that Nikki Haley is is in
the bag for Democrats who's getting
Democrat votes and and uh supporters and
voters she's getting voters and donors
and the idea one of the ideas that V
brought up which I thought was good is
why actually try and win a contest in in
November when all you have to do is try
and supplant Trump in the primary with
someone like Nikki Haley who is an
establishment favorite as well now I
don't know if How likely that's going to
be it looks like she's going to get you
just wiped out and then she doesn't have
any any opportunity to move forward
especially with the Sanda and vake now
being out of the race it's just her
she's not going anywhere but then you
have the potential of or the question
that we've brought up I've been saying
this for some time that Biden will not
be the nominee I think he is going to
drop out I think it's going to be health
reasons a JP Morgan strategist believes
that come March around super Tuesday
Biden will announce he's is dropping out
this opens the door so so uh many people
countered saying no they can't Tim it's
too late for a primary you and and and
the response is that's perfect it allows
them to avoid a Bernie Sanders situation
or a Marian Williamson or RFK situation
it allows them to stop any of these
candidates from Gaining traction and
gaining delegates so that when they as
you describe Roger Biden drops out they
can just at an open convention super
delegate Michelle Obama or Gavin Newsome
yeah they can control they can control
uh they can control the convention that
way but uh Michelle pardon me Camala
Harris is a problem for them because in
any normal scenario she'd be next in
line she's the sitting vice president uh
but they also fear she can't win an
election either that would be correct uh
and within and within the uh the
construct of their party she represents
a very important constituency she's a
woman of color so how do you justify
bypassing her I think the answer is is
Barack Obama persuades her that when the
first supreme court nomination becomes
available if they win the presidency in
control of the Senate she's a former
Attorney General of California she gets
that job she graciously steps aside uh
and we have a ticket that is comprised
of Michelle Obama for president uh and
Gavin Nome for vice president and Gavin
can raise hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of special interest dollars for
that ticket that's a good back room
explanation kamla Harris will be offered
a supreme court seat but they're not
going to publicly say that no she I
think it's actually really really simple
a lot of people said how do you get past
kamla Harris it's really simple Joe
Biden announces he's stepping down or
he's suffering a health issue kamla
Harris I I think there there there could
be an instance where Joe Biden actually
says I can no longer perform my duties I
need kamla to serve as acting president
kamla simply says I will not try to seek
a presidency when I'm filling this role
it would be it would be irresponsible or
or uh you know it would be wrong to try
and win an election this this late in
the game I'll just do my duties and then
bow out here's why I don't think that
happens I think Joe needs to maintain
the legal authority to Pardon his son
and his brother and himself and the
other members of the Biden crime family
uh he's wanted this he's wanted this job
his entire life uh I I don't think Dr
Jill's anxious to go by any means uh so
I think I once thought I once agreed
with you I thought he left early I don't
think he leaves early I think he fills
out the term but just doesn't run I mean
they're all one big happy family tree
son you know what I mean committing
treason so uh I'm I'm half kidding why
wouldn't he just along with his cronies
go to Kamala and say uh look pardon
Hunter me and anybody else I'll bow out
two months 3 months four months or
whatever it's all yours because it would
eradicate her political career she gets
to be the first female president well if
she pardoned all those people it would
be like a taint on her life for the next
30 or 40
gu it did cost Gerald Ford
reelection very narrow Race by pardoning
Nixon had he not paron Nixon I think he
would have won he lost by a hair he lost
a very close race and that was two years
after Watergate I mean think about it
come on they go to kamla and say how
would you like to be the first female
president in history your name will
never be forgotten all you got to do
pardon the Biden crime family you're not
going to run for re-election we'll then
move you to a suem Court seat or
something like this but you will be in
the history books forever she says deal
who would not want their name to be on
that plaque do you risk voters who are
wanting the new Democratic uh nominee to
be a woman of color like splitting the
votes at any deleg at any convention
between her and Michelle Obama if you do
that I suppose there is the argument
that Michelle Obama is the is the
nominee they could they would be saying
this could be the first woman of color
to ever be president you have to vote
for her and then try and go for the woke
angle that's that's You' already done it
with Cala so right so you burn that one
out but you know it's it's perhaps that
it I I I I how do you publicly get past
kamla Harris they've really created an
obstacle for themselves which is sort of
hilarious because I think when they
started they really thought maybe she
can be the era parent maybe it'll be
fine which is crazy I I don't think they
thought that I think they were like we
can't have stagi old white man with all
these progressives you need a woman of
color in there somewhere yeah I think
she doesn't even know why she's there
actually think Biden accidentally
painted himself in a corner I don't
think it was in the plan he blurred it
out I'm going to have a vice president
who's going to be a woman of color he
just he just said it is that illegal
violation of the 1964 Civil Rights Act
One of these things that we had
overturned affirmative action at that
point so you know what it's been driving
me a little sideways regarding the
Supreme Court you mentioned that the
Obamas might go to KLA Harris and be
like well we would consider you for the
Supreme Court or that they would just
put her in the Supreme Court like do we
have nine people making decisions for
the entire state of Texas that's like I
appreciate apprciate what it what it's
done and how it stands and how it
questions the legislature and how it can
overturn presidential Authority and
stuff but giving this kind of mass
authority to nine people that are
appointed they're not even voted into
office they're appointed by some
political Zealot some president and then
confirmed like that's so much power for
such a small group of people I don't
know it's great I love it I think it's
beautiful it's the it's one of the
brilliant things in the US
constition as long as the court is
indeed not politicized and then when
when a politicized person gets appointed
they they're there for life like there's
that that should be overturn like there
should be ter LI or something one of the
smartest political creations of mankind
is the American form of government and
we take it for granted because we grew
up in it but when the founding fathers
were trying to put together this system
they really did make the best that has
been so far can it be better always
there there are ways to improve that's
why the Constitution can be amended so
uh are there faults can we improve we
always can we always should look for
ways to do so but at the time the
American system of government is a
masterpiece and to this day still stands
as the best form of government in the
world and when the Supreme Court ruled
against some some aspects of the New
Deal Franklin Roosevelt tried exactly
that to expand the court to pack the
court it did not go over well and he
failed what did he do uh he put forward
a proposal to expand the court and it
was defeated in the Senate so n there
were nine then there's nine nine there's
nine then there's nine now he wanted
more the argument is that uh what what
do we have 12 districts how many think
that's right pellet districts or
whatever that there should be a judge
for each um region I it's been so long
since I've we've covered this stuff
heavily but the the reason why it's
brilliant is if you if you break it down
to the most rudimentary of forms you
have a group of people who just declared
independence you had the Articles of
Confederation you did not have a
constitution you had a very weak
government and they're trying to figure
out like what how how do we run this
thing and then someone says we should
have a King George Washington he should
be king and they're like no no no we
can't have a king because then George
may be great but what about his kids and
then his corruption okay well what about
like a direct democracy what if people
just voted no because then people vote
for stupid things and you need some
expertise in there okay what about like
a Council of Elders appointed
individuals who are of of great standing
within their communities and so you have
a how about all three how about we have
a Council of Elders a direct democrac a
representative democracy or with I
should say a represent constitutional
rep representative Republic
and a strong executive we do all three
and we make them fight each other checks
and balances how about we don't just
choose one of these governments we've
seen before we do all of them yeah but
if we're actually talking about making
kamla Harris on our Council of Elders
like what what have we done to our
national wisdom she's not someone I
would think of as like an elder wise man
this is the beauty of the system she she
would be eligible for appointment is
subject to confirmation of the US Senate
like any other Citizen and and a a a
truly good system doesn't just always
have god tier perfect people running the
show the the the idea that one Supreme
Court Justice is bad I think shows that
there is flexibility within the system
if we had a single Monarch sure you have
problems you're talking about katangi
Brown Jackson how old is she because
you're talking about Council of Elders
like what's her age is she really wise
is a figure of speech I'm saying it's
not supposed to be though it really is
supposed to be the wisest Among Us that
sit on the Supreme Court for life
and people are chosen and then confirmed
by the Senate and the problem here is
the 17th amendment should be uh uh what
are your thoughts on the 17th I think we
should get rid of it I'm not I think it
was Ben sass who first proposed not not
first but what is the 17th that the
Senate is chosen by popular vote in the
states as opposed to the state
representatives used to be done by the
state legislator the state legislator
would choose US senators uh and then
they changed it so they were done by
direct election of the and that's a
mistake and this is what causes part of
the problem when you have people voting
locally for their state reps those reps
know about your local issues your
sitting member of Congress knows a
little bit but they're going to DC and
they're voting on war and Omnibus
spending bills or whatever so if you go
and vote for a state senator or a state
rep and you say to them you know old uh
Crossland Creek over there is full of
garbage we need someone to get the job
done they go yeah I've seen it cuz I
live not too far away local
representation that
all of these people go to their session
and say who are we going to send to the
federal government to represent our
state and they will choose who they
think the best person is this creates
state representation as opposed to
National Democrat representation so the
problem now is the Democratic party says
we want Democrats we need Statewide
voting and it's all about some federal
policy as opposed to what's going on in
your state which results in Senators who
will confirm anybody so long as they're
Party Line shills then you end up with a
katangi brown who says I don't know what
a woman is it's like oh wow so that's a
problem I agree and sure we should
repeal the 17th I think with the
internet I I I disagree I I like the
direct election of senators otherwise
you all you get are career politicians
there never would ever be an opening for
anyone else so the politicians basically
choose the US senators there's a time in
New Jersey when two brothers were US
senators at the same time why they were
chosen by the New Jersey state
legislature back in the 20s yeah I I I
get that uh I disagree it' be I think if
if people people no one no one pays
attention at all to state representation
anymore and so now you get these ads
which are remarkable to me where it is a
person running for a federal house seat
in Congress saying if you vote for me
I'm going to fix our district and clean
things no you're not you're going to go
to DC and represent the district to to
the federal government you're going to
vote on whether or not we bomb a country
or how taxes are at the federal level
you're not going to vote at all on how
we deal with garbage in our city that's
a local rep a mayor a councilman who
does that people don't care anymore we
could do like an addendum to the 17th
Amendment where like state governments
will select their Senators but then the
the citizens have to confirm them to the
Senate via a vote and if they deny that
then maybe the citizens could vote for
their own yeah what about what about the
state reps will select and it has to be
confirmed by popular vote and then if
it's overturned then the populace can
vote for someone they want it's
overturned the state legislature has to
go back and renominate and then approve
another somebody else I mean that's a
step I like that like no names like can
come out of the S Side Lane and be like
yo the people love me and I'm the best
for the job even though the people at
the state government don't know who I am
and that person might get a shot at the
Senate I like that too but I I I don't
you know I just don't think you'll ever
get you'd never get any Outsiders
elected you'd always get people who are
part of the system cuz if the state
could just keep nominating insiders over
and over and you have to keep saying no
no no no at some point the population's
got to be able to put their own person
there always a family that's involved in
state politics or several of them in
every state I mean there's sort of a a
control right thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time